violin bow on a saw okay no I thought
that was Chucky in your pocket dog was
so full podcast Felipe Esparza with
Rogelio Torres yeah man what's up back
from soccer take us bro all the way from
Mexico this fools over there drinking
tequila shots were scorpions in them he
was eating um [ __ ] una tacos
yeah he was over there man living like a
senator wearing suits lying to everybody
about what he's doing on America hanging
out with politicians were too fatty ass
we're to Paul Anka's rooster fights hey
over there when you were Mexico mental
ray strikes there's the most radar hell
yeah but with the mad drag racing's
issue of when you got two hours um your
whole travel when you got when you were
like I was it long with a long airline
no I dude it was [ __ ] cool the plane
was half full dogs [ __ ] customs was
easy for you mean crept in their [ __ ]
eighth duck was the first night [ __ ]
delicious tacos [ __ ] cover so I'll do
it I'll pass door right there for the
outside as a pina right there hell yeah
you had a little sit-down area but we're
right there by the taco bar you know
dude let me tell you dog it dude tacos
are good here you can make them but
they're just better over there fool
that's like a [ __ ] taquito that's
what that fool does he's a taquito dog
he's not a mechanical he's not a [ __ ]
husband none of that [ __ ] that fools
makes [ __ ] tacos dog they're just
[ __ ] bleeding mad flavor dog I'm
serious phul just [ __ ] I can't even do
you of course you can describe but this
[ __ ] just [ __ ] delicious dog this is
smelly dog what did you go to on
vacation or what oh no I don't know
[ __ ] vacation these fools had me
working dog well yeah I would just do it
over there for three days a monk on a
[ __ ] rant and run around getting [ __ ]
done getting [ __ ] welded bringing
workers back making sure the [ __ ]
bales of hay were counted all this [ __ ]
dude but it's all good but my cousin got
married on Wednesday on Saturday so
that's why
I really do that fool came over here
like three years ago and [ __ ] him I'll
[ __ ] return the favor say hello would
you get married to him some little chick
oh my his sister's friend was 27 the
chicks 30 dog buck and the chick told
them a muhfucka we don't get married
it's over there a big wedding
it was [ __ ] probably bout what 250
people lot of food a lot of fools over
there [ __ ] drinking it up oh you know
muff well-focused taking the ashtrays it
[ __ ] that the order in stood me little
thieves dog I started think of that a
big city it's uh it's it's that's the
biggest city there it's an old colonial
city since 1500s but Sarcoptes is one of
the poorest [ __ ] you know states in
Mexico dog a lot of unemployment a lot
of poor as fools a lot of poor ass
there's sections there where you walk in
the river Jack yo ass they used to be in
Fez neo which is about 45 minutes from
socket tech as a capital five years ago
that's when the set does were running
around you couldn't [ __ ] around if you
go over there burnin rubber and [ __ ]
[ __ ] pull you over in trucks
Yankee the [ __ ] out and Spanky dog
warning number one warning number two
you don't be around anymore but now
Chiapas people are in there so they're
[ __ ] kind of clearing the [ __ ] he
don't [ __ ] with people that's why people
love Chapel dog because he doesn't go in
there try to extort your [ __ ] but um
how about the time well there's not a
bunch of kids in ship-borne runaway kids
it's a robbery boos that's what happened
was checked up yeah well that's what was
going on during the [ __ ] so when that
SEPTA's came in dude all those little
kids turn into Alcorn is what I'll cone
is our little fools on bikes that are
lookouts dog I'll tell you when the cops
are coming to tell you when the shit's
clear and then the fools go in there
with the [ __ ] heavy alter alter
artillery and [ __ ] your ass up dog yeah
man so that's [ __ ] going down a lot of
shits going down right now our like the
weed game fool you can't really you have
to keep it on the DL dog you can't even
really hero is over there i blaze once
full with the Medrano dog I [ __ ] was
chillin at that bar was taking those
shots dude and I seen a big fat fool
what can any look like Paulie from
Goodfellas by a young version I was like
[ __ ] I was like nah that way [ __ ] I
haven't seen him in like five years dude
and everybody knows in there and that
full blazes that's a fool they [ __ ]
told me about back in the day about
churros that's what he calls joints now
cover and think of what's there to lose
weight so I'm a fool what the [ __ ]
killing that way I will mock it by the
way see whether they mr lumic what they
were in that will call this fool their
own a little restaurant a little ball
fool dog it's been over here but got
kicked out and that fool had weed but
it wasn't good as we'd like the wheat
here just doesn't compare the [ __ ] but
the [ __ ] doesn't have any chemicals but
it's grown in the Sierras but it's
really basically got me a head change
yes it's it's clean stress it's you know
it's not bomb ass [ __ ] but they don't
grind it up perfectly smoke we're trying
to make rid you sound good
original Reggie dog right there dog so I
got hi little head change but that was
it but supposedly bad joint or what not
just fat balls out of those [ __ ] old
school cork balls full they detach and
[ __ ] and you can taste that little wood
and [ __ ] each of my E's dog but you
can't be [ __ ] around like showing
people you smoke weed because if a full
rows up from a different cartel because
they're about three fractions they're
right now
where'd you get that from oh no I did I
don't do nothing I don't [ __ ] it's know
where the [ __ ] you get that from if
you don't tell them they'll beat your
ass and then after you tell them that
will beat your ass just to figure out
who's selling it's kind of on the DL
standard for now because they're the one
the one they don't want only they're
people selling you know oh yeah that
shit's [ __ ] mad controlled right now
and it's like kind of like a struggle do
cuz there's three cartels in there and
one fading away the one is fading away
is the big Z's yeah
she's [ __ ] creates different laws
dogs there's no hot chicks over there
yeah full but they don't be wanting a
pipe dog yeah you get another no they're
either oh oh - country I'll take it try
taking a [ __ ] house on [ __ ] what
happened man those chicks are just they
want [ __ ] you somebody that owns two
ranches all these [ __ ] those chicks over
there - like over here they want ballers
now oh hell yeah
will they be thrilled dude they don't
want they want to get married and get
taken care of dog who the [ __ ] wants a
bleak future over 20 years man you could
just get a chick oh there's it because
you speak English hell yeah new shoes
food but those chicks over those speak
English - now I yeah it's it's she's
changing - people are on it dawg social
media all that [ __ ] for different world
dog you didn't hook up name it once not
even once for damn we didn't have time
but nevertheless Brian I'm saying you
need to try hooking one of those
employees today I'm gonna give you the
broom detail thought it was taco this
year oh no I do you [ __ ] butt about
go I do Billy I do quesadillas dude
[ __ ] a dude owes do recalled Doritos
dog which is just [ __ ] fried [ __ ]
pork skin you know without the fat dude
with chili on top of their head is dog
right there where we czars from that she
was just all types of liquor and beer
and [ __ ] up near a park called podcaster
telling those fools to listen on there
and [ __ ] uh got some listeners there
but they say it's bigger in the bigger
cities do like Mexico the fa1 Monterey
cuz they're all industrialized and
everybody's trying to be more hip more
American and [ __ ] you know I mean it's a
lot to NAS over there
of course whoo - from the bottom all the
way up dog you just tell her you know
that they're all Mexican you could tell
who the lowest ah hell yeah there's some
mad poverty out there black boots
dad you fool there's a black fool on the
[ __ ] basketball team fool and there's
a black full on the soccer team but the
black bull form on the soccer team is
from Jamaica and other fools here from
the states will from Georgia fool was
some fool people don't forget if you're
going to search for something on Amazon
search through the Amazon search window
on our website and you'll be
contributing a little something toward
the podcast every time you do that and
end up buying something if we go to the
Filippis world webpage and then you go
to amazon on our web page and you go buy
something we get a little something just
give you even searched on it all right
upcoming shows improv in San Jose
tonight
September 4th through the 6th Comedy
Works in downtown Denver Colorado
September 23rd to the 26 parlor live in
Seattle Washington October 8 through 10
lever alive in West Nyack New York
October 22nd to the 25th the return the
last time we were snowed in right oh
yeah for one night but they [ __ ] had
bomb Chinese food over there oh yeah
where's night when you got some bomb-ass
guru's lizard if you live near West
Nyack area and want to see one of these
shows October 22nd to the 25th ok
October 22nd through 25th west night New
York every live if you want to come to
this show for free just email us at fans
at Filippis world.com and tell them you
heard
on free West Nyack tickets on the
podcast free with night ticket on the
podcast and also don't be a dick an
idiot and email us asking about other
cities this is only for West Nyack right
now West Nyack New York also shout out
to be run Barbie was similarly Ribeira
Bobby just beer up Bobby be run Bobby
from the bureau I'm Bobby only show in
San Jose California he was an old his
show in a bear area and that for used to
book me a comedy shows every book you so
twice he pulling my comedy shows and he
always paid me he paid me Mabel me is
one ghetto-ass comedy show at the
Emerald in or the Emerald something
nothing but veteranos I bet there are
laws bro like everybody from the little
homie Dog soda
every single one from the homemade dog
showed up even the blind fool cholo with
a dog he was outside in the back
listening was his dog was sleeping even
though cholo they graduated and all of
them were a fat man they were fat
[ __ ] mean as Chicanos a fat
fool with big fists and big ass
lowriders anyways shout out to be round
Barbie man thank you for for booking me
and those comedy shows back in the days
when nobody else was looking me in the
San Jose improv which I'm hella in this
week you know and I'm I to do the family
improv I should do some of the improv on
Wednesdays then Thursday night show go
do a show in San Francisco
Friday night show pretty much get
annihilated and hung out somewhere in
hated on people and called up comedy
clubs and Friday night I will go do the
Purim Bobby show at the Emerald in yeah
man or evergreen wherever a while man
and our Foolish to work gold suit bro
solid gold dawg
I saw that I was driving up and I said
that be around Bobby and I hear like
Slayer hair back
you know oily you know not oily but I'm
you know the Florida style uh-huh this
style and he were wearing a gold suit
fool like a gold suit you know that word
Little Richard I think you know forty
answer and I say what if you're gonna
drink a 40 ounce err on the side of a
liquor store you better do it with a
gold suit bro that's the way he did it
bo-buddies shot out bro thank you
rodrigo tourist shot out yeah man fool
chillin
um char out turkey store bought
Rodriguez over there out of [ __ ]
Calexico your shirt will be there Friday
shoutout to Petra Bella and Joe you guys
a shirt should be there Friday and thank
you very much for listening you guys
please keep spreading the word
also man we have here from UM from
Ontario Canada grew up on an army base
actor rapper writer comedian producer
director talk show host got a mainstream
audience from an MTV show the Tom Green
show when I was in college we used to
watch it yeah dude this will had this
one he had his a homie with the red hair
that you always used to [ __ ] with he
left him under a bridge one time all
[ __ ] cold and he made a paper mache
[ __ ] I think of his dad beating his
mom hey big dog chili what's up fool I
got some green as our honor we're
honoured life yeah right you got you're
trying to Blue Jays have representing
just for you thank you very much
appreciate that I'm Canadian
we're in it yeah absolutely I know yeah
that's thank you so at the underground
comedy can't make underground comedy
cafes yeah mama in Toronto half mama
yeah and nice a fan made me this t-shirt
what's the name Tom Green David Green
yeah made mother a guy from Toronto it's
not like Georgia true they make this it
was his names on the back Harley green
yeah green as well my name is green yeah
their name was green teams
- I'm from I'm from Canada he's from
Canada yeah my name is Green his name is
green Amy this room the best a lot of
coincidences here oh that's nice
very good 69 number 69 your favorite
number that's my favorite number right
Oh what's up I mean in the house hell
yeah Canada's finest good to be here
yeah thanks you came into my web over in
show the other day on my website on Tom
Green Comm
did you have fun we had a hell of fun
fun right yeah little people watched it
yeah we tweeted it we tweeted it be
social media tip up and you invited
people who would you invite every
weekend let donors shop right yeah
absolutely I'll be there today I go to a
donut shop the donut prince a donut
print every every Wednesday every day
I'm in town doing my show which is
weekdays whenever I'm in Los Angeles I
meet people whoever wants to meet me at
the donut Prince donut shop in Burbank
just follow my twitter at Tom Green live
and if you want to be in the studio
audience of my web of Asian show meet me
at the donut Prince a lot of weird
things about that sentence that I just
used unlike I mean I don't know do you
think anybody understands what I'm
talking about right now we're just like
crazy weirdo showing up like yeah like
yeah yeah you wanna be my vision show
meet me at a donut shop what the hell is
this Canadian talking about do you get
that a weirdos who show up at the donut
shop yeah but no more people actually
it's people I thought maybe we would but
people are pretty awesome I think
anybody that's watching my show and then
watching my Twitter and then decides
that they want to go to a donut shop to
come to my show usually they're pretty
creative interesting people that decide
to do that that's the thing I've noticed
is I think crazy people tend to be more
you know like you know they stay at home
they don't leave the house a lot I know
this because I am a crazy perfect
keyboard warriors and [ __ ] yeah yeah I
was telling Philippe dude I used to
watch her show in college and [ __ ] and
you had this one where you had a paper
mache a statue of your dad beating your
mom you're like um outside check it out
dad got all pissed and started ripping
it down
and have a sex that was the one of them
having that in sex with each other yeah
they did they threaten to sue MTV over
that bed your folks
yeah they had only been on MTV for a few
months maybe only a month or so and I'd
done pranks on them for years in Canada
and might put him on public access TV
now all of a sudden I was on MTV I had a
budget we flew back we made statues of
them having sex put them on the front
lawn the neighbors saw the statues my
parents were embarrassed and angry they
threatened to sue MTV they left a
message on that answering machine at MTV
MTV had an answering machine still in
1999 that's how fast the world changes
Wow
they said if you guys air that bit we're
gonna sue you bastards for 1 million
dollars was my father's message to MTV
which I'm sure scared Viacom you know 1
million dollars Canadian that's that's
700,000 dollars but then so they
wouldn't let us air that bit you know
this parents having sex statues bit they
weren't gonna let us air at MTV wasn't
gonna let Eric cuz they didn't wanna get
sued by my parents and an Oprah Winfrey
contacted the show this is how fast that
show took off on MTV been living in New
York for about a month and Oprah Winfrey
contacted the show and said she wanted
to book my parents and I on Oprah to
play the [ __ ] mobile which is the video
where I painted pornography on my
parents car so that was fine for Oprah
and so we went to Chicago with my
parents and we went on Oprah and we
played all the other pranks the the the
sex statues one hadn't aired yet no one
had seen that one yet my parents were
like still mad at me but then after we
went on Oprah I got them to sign a
release Foreman and let me air the clip
because they were so proud that they got
to go on Oprah they were so proud that
they forgave me for the sex statues
that's hilarious and Oprah sent them to
Tahiti for 16 days and a cruise so that
was
pretty cool that was cool weird times
weird time Thank You Oprah for the sex
statues with a known would have seen the
sex statues if it wasn't for Oprah
really no one would have ever seen that
because my parents would have never let
us let us air it but I had the release
form in my back pocket the entire time I
was on Oprah we went out for dinner
after and my parents I think we're just
sort of in shock that they just met
Oprah so I was able to trick him into
signing the release for him
sneaky Danish yeah just snuck it in
there in the menu I wasn't too late was
I no no you were on time I know I like
to be on time but then I just had to
park way down the street and and and
also I was late straight up was late I'd
like to be on time then I say my excuse
for why I was late which is no excuse I
had to park four blocks away I should
have planned on the fact that parking is
always a factor when you're going
somewhere in Los Angeles right I hate
when people say oh sorry I was late
there was traffic
there's always [ __ ] traffic me it's
an hour to get to it always were a
factor that in yeah you can't leave at
3:30 and expect to be there at 4:00
anywhere there's really no excuse right
for me to be here ten minutes late you
could have said um I was studying in
line outside with the people from the
price is right but they're not out there
tonight I didn't know the show was gonna
start right at noon I thought was the
kind of thing that is are we live right
now no we're not live longer this won't
air Friday yeah today how long is the
show and now we're now we're and a half
just go and tell yo stop we stop oh so
you could steal you could start and I
wander in laughs probably more fun that
way yeah we were talking about him
because he was in Mexico and he was
drinking tequila with some live
scorpions inside of them
oh no they weren't live there already uh
you know taken care of yeah stiff yeah
but there's new on it though [ __ ] no I
just let that [ __ ] slide uh yeah 34 king
scorpions I've had a mascara with the
worm at the bottom okay and that's what
it was it was my Scylla buttons
with scorpions uh-huh nice then they
light it on fire you blow it out Jim I
have another boo the toenail entire toe
bro like mezcal with a worm ISM isn't
hardcore enough well I meant Tom Green
and Eric Andre's party yeah you said in
the desert I said the pictures of [ __ ]
crazy it wasn't them it was like a
trailer park area in the middle of the
desert Hicksville yeah Higgs field
trailer park palace there's a badass
little trip trailers all airliners are
all different little houses and shooting
a little community yeah well cool man
and then now we're always thinking happy
birthday to Eric Andre and he got butt
naked yeah there's a lot of nudity
they're running around hugging people
butt naked too much nudity yeah I don't
need to see that no I don't want to see
it oh so no I was trying to slowly you
know like you know like you start slowly
that you start seeing something bad
starting you slowly wanna walk away no
you want a moonwalk backwards yeah I was
slowly doing that when he approached me
he jumped on means in it
we made it yeah yeah you been out to
Joshua Tree before
yeah I always wanted to go but I never
been there it's a nice place I love the
desert I was just in Phoenix this
weekend doing stand-up at the at the
standup live in Phoenix you played that
Club no I do the Tempe yeah I've uh I've
always done Tempe to this first time I
did stand-up life 111 degrees in Phoenix
today Dan 111 degrees I went to
breakfast one morning I said I asked the
guide to hotel
where's a good place to Brett get
breakfast and he said it's a like 10
blocks down that way right and so I said
well can I walk he said yeah he can walk
so I started walking five blocks there I
was like five blocks into the walk I
burst into flames
man those hotel people never know how
far she dude yeah but they just don't
care cuz they're used to walking around
110 degree tell you all the most is
right over there and you walk and you
get to walk through a freeway Oh
seven blocks away plus a [ __ ]
overpass yeah it was crazy then then I
finished the weekend two shows at a
great weekend and then I thought you
know I'm gonna drive I drove yeah
whenever whenever it's less than six
hours of drive I Drive you know usually
I'm on a plane you know you don't Slyke
you're in a plane all the time right so
that's like okay well and a drive so I
drove and then I got there and I did my
shows and then I thought the Grand
Canyon's in Arizona I'm gonna go to
Grand Canyon on the way home it's not on
the way home doesn't have to us
three-hour detour yeah three-hour detour
I knew it was but I just wanted I don't
know that yeah cuz sometime when I'm
driving to Sacramento I think maybe I'll
go to the redwood trees yeah but that's
another three hours all right wait but I
did it I made that decision to the Grand
Canyon I knew what I was getting into
and I did it I just said you know what
I'm gonna go to the Grand Canyon on the
way to LA from Phoenix so I drove up to
Flagstaff after my show Sunday night
checked into a little hotel then I got
up in the morning and I drove over to
the Grand Canyon another hour and then I
just went and I just sat there and
looked at it for like two or three hours
then I drove home was seven hours drive
so it was basically 14-hour driving and
sitting day oh the Grand Canyon is the
nicest time it's a nice canyon it's
really big as granda it is a Grand
Canyon that's why they called it that
it's amazing you ever been there there
bird yeah it's worthwhile I mean there
was a minute where I thought I wasn't
gonna be able to find it I thought how
stupid am I that I can't find the
biggest thing in the country but I drove
right to it and then I was driving
through these trees and stuff I
literally was no I knew I was you know a
hundred meters from it and I just
thought am I gonna be the idiot that
drives all the way the Grand Canyon and
can't find it but I found it and it was
nice did you pass by Sedona I did yeah
pastors don't know from there but I
drove through there a night oh because I
was I drove through and I stopped and I
stayed in
Wagstaff flax Devas cold in the winter
yeah yeah but it's nothing compared to
Canada cold so I can handle that's right
yeah I got the Canada cold so we were
originally from Ottawa Ottawa yeah the
capital right Oh capital
yeah capital Canada the Canada in
Ontario
yeah the capital yeah nobody knows that
it's the capital no was there yeah I
love that I mean Americans all the time
some of them who I've known for 15 years
and I asked them what the capital is of
Canada and these are people that know me
that know that I grew up in Ottawa the
capital of Canada and they'll say
Toronto or Montreal or Montreal Quebec
yeah katt Canada's capital is Ottawa
it's a nice City it's about a million
people three hundred and fifty thousand
but if you include the whole region it's
a million so it's a small city but it's
nice it's sort of like I'd say it's kind
of like I don't know Grand Rapids
Michigan kind of like that but it's got
nice nice architecture and things like
that the Parliament Buildings are quite
nice it's like I like growing up in
small cities because there's nothing
really like there's no there's nothing
to worry about you know like you never
have to worry about anything bad
happening it's just a nice little city
no drive-bys no crime no it's just a
nice crime free safe city that's I think
why the show that I did started out
being kind of weird like we go on the
street do weird stuff cuz then we go out
in the street we mess with people on the
street because you know I'd never really
had to worry about you know getting shot
or anything like that yeah
and then when we moved to America and
did the show literally the first shoot
shoot we did in America
I got basically got beat up really well
almost Iran the hostility here I would
have beat me up if he'd caught me but he
didn't catch me I'm a fast runner
soon long I'll a guy chased me with a
hammer are you serious the first day of
shooting first time I shot a prank video
in America with Italian ah he was
American
[ __ ] him there's a long island god
there's a long island guy angry it's
weird because I was actually this egg in
the bit the whole premise of the bit was
I was actually doing something nice for
people and he still wanted to beat me up
it was called under cutters pizza
where I would I went to a pizza chained
and I sat in my car outside the pizza
chain and when the pizza delivery guy
delivered the pizza I would follow the
pizza guy to the place he was making the
delivery and then I had a plain pizza in
with me and I had a fishing tackle box
full of you know makes with cheese and
toppings and mushrooms and tomatoes and
stuff and I would follow the pizza guy
up to the door and then he was trying to
sell the pizza to the guy I'd say no I'm
gonna give you the same pizza for
cheaper and it was called under cutters
pizza I was gonna undercut the
competition and it was supposed to be
the pizza guy that got mad at me
supposed to be the pizza guy that wanted
to kick my ass but for some reason it
was the guy who who was the guy who I
was delivering summer the customer
wanted to kick my ass
didn't make any sense I was offering him
a deal tobey's be a yeah who's out there
working on his car and he's ha ha ha ha
they start chasing me with a hammer
and he had the hammer up he was coming
at me with a hammer we would have killed
me all for a no cuz I was given trying
to give him a discount pizza there's
slashing prices and helping that fool
out I was just like these Americans are
crazy so he started you were a rapper at
one time worst huh yeah kinda like kid
MC Canadian hip-hop for the mean streets
of Ottawa oh wow
yeah Aldi wrath yeah well I I made I
made a lot beats I made beats and I I
was was in high school and so me too
early that were you a rapper yes now
two rhymes yeah oh sure you like rather
shirt though kid MC yeah [ __ ] love
Run DMC yeah me too
so I that's when I sort of got into rap
was when Run DMC Public Enemy groups
like that LL Cool J LL Cool J boys these
two Beastie Boys I was my favorites were
Public Enemy be sore makes a nice run
DMC and I was a little later but yeah
sir mix-a-lot was good Tribe Called
Quest was bad boys Fat Boy bad boys are
bad yeah yeah
they were that was my first vinyl record
Fat Boys crush and I led Dougie fresh
yeah yeah those were those were the ones
those were the days but so yeah I
started making beats I was I was always
into like computers and stuff so I got a
computer and I started making beats and
I had a sampler and an acai s 950
sampler and a Atari computer hooked up
to a role and keyboard and a Yamaha drum
machine and recording offers beuter
style yeah that in fact is Ferris
Bueller make beats no he made that look
cough that cough beat oh it was me when
it was a member yeah oh yeah yeah do
that according to your writing [ __ ]
you're right he did do that yes I
remember that love Ferris Bueller yeah
so those were the days and we did the we
did the rapping but never really went
anywhere
we did we did get it we did an album we
did a video it's on YouTube yeah the
band was called organized rhyme if you
look it up I don't know if you have that
technology to play it on youtube
everybody listening look up organized
rhyme on youtube organized rhyme yeah I
need to yeah everything is YouTube was
your MC name MC bones Ron suppose bones
rocket in my bone like a king on a
throne only thing as I stand alone
Robert rhymes like that was pretty
[ __ ] rough but uh we were ill dope
emcees but yeah we we got together again
the group got back together at the Just
for Laughs comedy festival and we all
three years ago and we performed there
that was pretty fun I stared up got the
LA baya threw down since
is universe we're on here yeah okay yeah
it's a podcast right yes where I'm out
we go that's more foul-mouthed empty
face uh well that was that was an alter
ego character that was a like that was
another rapper that wasn't me MC face
was another rapper but I made the beats
em some face was someone else
I was MC face never going down in
disgrace and he had a we had beef yeah
MC face and I had beef with each other
it was like a it's like an not like a
biggie Tupac East Coast West Coast
rivalry except this was just an East End
West End of Ottawa rivalry ah
he was an East End guy no I don't I
guess I was from I don't know I'm
talking about but it was fun yeah I'm
glad I made a lot of goofy music over
the years I like making music I might
make some more music this year I I did
this song called the bum bum song on MTV
and it went to number one on Total
Request Live when I was on MTV and not
knock Britney Spears off the countdown
and I hear she was really upset about
that really yeah no I don't think she
even heard about it yeah it was cool
though it was cool how about you guys
how do you two know each other
mean this fool yeah Oh doing a stand-up
comedy show in Montebello California oh
wow Oh California okay not Montebello
Quebec no it's a ballad California yeah
the 60 yeah it was a biker bar well they
considered a biker bar but it wasn't
really a biker bar but a lot of bikers
showed up yeah and a lot of thugs that
cholos and a lot of women because it was
comedy and then as soon as comedy and
then at 10 it was dancing
ah you're freaking out freaking out
again yeah I love people dancing
grooving you guys it into Tupac yeah I
was bumping back then it was a bumpy man
that song um
California love cuz I'm a ho you know
I'm a ho a rock to Jeffery host after
every show because I'm a ho ho
and I'll be in the back just dancing by
the bar I think girls dance you know
hahahaha the rest of the guys are
dancing we'll go to the bathroom I ghost
sneak in dancing like like little
crucita from blood in blood out
what was it was that so that sounds like
a good a good gig rent
we had it for like ten years with no
budget Wednesday and Saturday nights
Wednesday Saturday nights nice was a
killer spot the line was always wrapped
around the building we charge like five
bucks to get in at the end oh nice
wait where's Montebello California how
far is that from 40 minutes from here
razor here 30 minutes 25 minutes east of
brain prep oh right cool
yeah 50 minutes right around here okay
good yeah for the brain bro yeah yeah
I've been there like that so you started
off when you were 15 years old doing
stand-up coming Yuk Yuk's
yeah yuk yuk see ya you know the owner
yeah my friend yeah yeah he's great guy
yeah I know mark I know I was in Ottawa
so I was at the Ottawa Yuk Yuk's Powys
the manager there and owner there so so
yeah I had a great time doing that when
I was a kid I started doing it I did it
for like you know three or four years
and I quit quit doing stand-up why
because the rap group took off had to
focus on the rapping MC bones fool we
got uh we got like a record deal and I
went off and I did this record and and I
was gonna focus on rapping I was gonna
be a rapper took it real serious then
that didn't work out so I went back to
school and took television broadcasting
and then I started my show on public
access started the Tom Green show on
public access TV in Canada did do
stand-up for a long time like like 10
years or so and then did the show up I
did the show you know constantly for 10
years that's all i all i all i did was
worried about the show you started a
whole senior show in college yeah it was
in college I was in I was in college and
some friends from college and I went
down to the TV station and we
volunteered and we did this show we put
it on Thursday nights and it's basically
like the show that I'm doing now
the show that you did last week yeah
it's like that it was the same thing it
was like you know we made the show up
herself
there was no Network sometimes I wonder
if that's something wrong with me I mean
I've been doing this for 30 years and
I'm doing the exact same thing that I
was doing when I was a kid living in my
parents basement now that's not good
right it's good you're like a pioneer
with that [ __ ] dude
yeah yeah no I like it I like
interactive though all right can I leave
a Karl in I love it I love doing what
I'm doing now because it's like what I
was doing 20 years ago meaning I don't
have a boss it's like a podcast but it's
a television show you know like you know
you don't have a boss when you do a
podcast all right you don't everybody
telling you what to say here no but most
radio shows right you got someone
telling you what to say
oh you can only talk for five minutes
then you got to play this song in that
song you don't have anyone telling you
what to do that's what I love about what
I'm doing now it's there's no network
you can't get cancelled can't get fired
I always wanted to have a job where I
couldn't get fired
that's what do the podcast yeah and
that's why I want to be a comedian
that's why I wanted to do do my own
thing and then as soon as I ended up on
MTV you know you have a boss and then
after that doing doing everything you
know in the mainstream broadcasting
industry you have a boss who can fire
you and it's sort of not really what
it's supposed to be right the whole
point is supposed to be there we're
supposed to be [ __ ] around do
whatever we want do crazy [ __ ] and
people enjoy it but then obviously you
have a boss who's done oh don't do your
crazy stuff that way do crazy stuff this
way and then it sort of negates the
whole point so that's why I like doing
what I'm doing now it's fun the draft
will submit all your sketches beforehand
on MTV or the little wing it well I'll
see the thing is that the reason why my
show was so weird is because we'd
already shot it all in Canada Oh most of
it on public access and so we didn't
have to run it past anybody on public
access we just did it and put it on TV
and then when MTV picked up the show we
just reared all that stuff but then that
then when we
I'm out of stuff then we had to start
shooting new stuff and that's when we
had to like write it down first and then
ask somebody if it was ok and then they
would say no and then we'd have to ask
if it was ok could you do it this way
please
we didn't to be a big argument and then
and then eventually we'd get it on the
air but it was really a very immediate
stark difference between what it was
like before when we were doing the show
in Canada that's why the Canadian clips
that we shot in Canada were a lot
weirder than the stuff that once we got
an MTV we had to sort of run everything
past somebody and then all the fun stuff
gets kind of stripped out of it
yeah the permits yeah yeah yeah everyone
had to sign a release form how do you do
that you know how do you get a guy who's
chasing you with a hammer facing you
with a hammer to sign a release form
give him a bag of nails you know yeah we
did get him to sign them we'd send girls
from the from the staff back attractive
women would go back with with release
forms after the chase they'd go back to
the hammer chase attractive lady would
go back the next day from MTV sometimes
with money offer him 50 bucks you know
it's like if you're working on your car
and Long Island and I you know you chase
a guy with a hammer who's trying to give
you a free pizza and then you cool down
and in the next day an attractive lady
shows up and wants to give you 50 bucks
you sign the release at that point Wow
normally I wouldn't but I like your
blouse yeah pretty much yeah yeah we had
to do as it was always a it was always
became a conflict because it was if we
get two people get too angry then they
won't sign the release form but it was
funny when they got angry so you'd have
to get him just angry enough that they
would still be convinced to sign a
release form when you did your when you
started on booking movies they just they
just let you be Tom Green or you have to
come up with care
Reuters cuz you're pretty much a scene
stealer in every movie especially
Charlie's Angels yeah yeah and I'm the
other one when you were taking everybody
running to college I like road trip yeah
that movie too
yeah those were movies that I got cast
in and I got asked to be in and so with
your Tom yeah they just asked me to be
in those but the one that I made myself
was Freddy got fingered oh yeah so that
one's like the the really weird one
which is sort of a big following now
yeah it came out though it didn't have a
big following when it came out the
critics said that it was the worst movie
ever made and then boom everybody had
that in a DVD yeah it was sort of a it's
the kind of thing that you get upset
about you know and yeah work your whole
life trying to do TV show and then you
get to make your first movie and you
make the movie and they say it's the
worst movie ever made you get upset when
that happens but then you know 15 years
later and and a lot of people think it's
their favorite movie so it's it's it's
all it's all fine now people people know
all the lines of that movie was fun but
you know I like I like doing films I'm
shooting the film this year in in
Belgium and actually in November going
to Belgium for a month and I'm gonna
film a movie over there called iron sky
it's the sequel to do iron sky it's
called iron sky - and and that's gonna
be cool so I like I like doing films but
I like I like doing this broadcasting
more and stand-up I like that more than
films you sure lad no huh
Louie stand up always yeah do a Cedar
Rapids two weeks ago constantly
constantly touring I love it and yeah go
to my website and get my tour dates and
come see me on the road I've chosen
Houston coming up Rodan Houston improv
yep Houston improv and in Austin at the
cap city comedy club and San Antonio at
the River City River Center comedy River
Center oh yeah I haven't played there
yet so that's gonna be fun you love that
city so the mall yeah
is it on the river yes yeah that makes
sense you could take actually you could
if you plan it out right you could um
how
one of the little boats meet you outside
your hotel nice turtle pick you up and
then ride you all the way to the mall
Wow and then you go to the river center
comedy club Wow so you can take a boat
to your show yes you're gonna like this
part on your San Antonio uh-huh
walk around and look at all the tourists
buy the Alamo and start asking the worst
pee-wee Herman's bike oh yeah I have
been to San Antonio before I just
haven't performed there I've been to
Dallas I always pass by when I'm with
the Allen boy yeah they're doing the
tour and I was American from the Midwest
yeah and I would say get to the part
where we kick their ass yeah that'll be
cool though because I'll be some good
periscoping good we do some periscoping
right you like periscoping yeah it's fun
I do a lot of periscope and I actually
think that's the reason why I drove the
Grand Canyon just because I wanted to
show my periscope
follow or something so it's nice
periscope gets you out of the house and
you can watch you can periscope anything
yeah yeah yeah dude isolated one time
this model schewe periscope and um
herself putting a kitchen cabinet
together the longest periscope in the
world and everybody was tight writing in
shortage we don't want to see handiwork
by the way you put a woman next to you
somebody a bra put her blouse down all
those creeps dog a lot of weird people
on the internet a lot of weird peon
animus hiding faces hey Ally eggs they
can say things that they would never
have the ability to say in real life
because they're anonymous anonymous yeah
they'll never say those things because
they'll know there'll be a guy for
chasing with a hammer yeah people forget
though that all that information is
totally tracked and you know you can you
can say some horrible thing on the
internet and forget that you know
literally that's searchable for the rest
of your life and at some point Google
will probably just get hacked and every
single bad thing that you've ever said
about anyone
we'll be immediately searchable to
anybody you know so if you're a person
out there that says negative things or
you know racist things or sexist things
or illegal things yes when you're saying
that all the time there's probably going
to be a day you know like this Ashley
Madison thing just got hacked and
everybody now their names are searchable
well they're gonna be a day in the not
so distant future where everything you
ever have written ever online is is
traceable to everybody so you could sit
down write in someone's name and
everything they've ever said comes all
there has to tell you they've posed up
every text message you've ever written
every photo you've ever sent to anybody
everything every video you've ever shot
every tweet every Facebook comment
everything that you thought was
anonymous will be immediately searchable
so you go apply for a job and then they
type your name and they read oh look
what you said about this person look
what you said look what you said so
haters out there on the internet better
learn to you know be nice because that's
gonna be traceable back to you I don't
write anything ever on any electronic
thing that I would not want public yes I
mean even just private things personal
conversation anything not even talking
about things that I you know I mean I I
mean just anything you know anything yep
talking your your girlfriend you gotta
be careful like you're on the road it
gets lonely on the road sometimes you
start thinking oh maybe I could have a
nice romantic evening on skype yeah just
be careful because that stuff clergy
routine every single video that you ever
shoot is saved and stored somewhere
everything like Google is building huge
databases out in Utah or something well
the government's doing that's about
seven fields long yeah and it's just
[ __ ] stacking mad information all
that [ __ ] oh yeah so if you're alive
you're on the road and you go I think
I'm gonna have a little sexy time on
FaceTime Oh sexy time with my lady
that's all saved forever
I like a hacker to one they did hack in
and do something really good for
everybody yeah I hacky
and hack into Twitter and guess what he
deleted everybody's messages permanently
yeah or just delete Twitter delete
Twitter or show up somewhere and fix
everybody's critic account yeah oh man
today oh man this guy this hacker came
in it oh yeah cleared up my credit back
up buy a house now do something good for
good man yeah yeah well guess what today
this hacker just gave me a million like
Robin Hood hacker oh man oh this guy
just took down my I am NOT Felipe
Esparza account finally would you hate
those is there an account that no but
there's one for everybody
those are coming down too well that's
the host winners coming down now and
taking down the fake account like if you
have somebody that says Tom green but
he's not Tom Green yeah I was putting on
hate every day yeah and have the million
followers yeah that purse is not gonna
be deleted yeah that's what he's talking
about all that unofficial [ __ ] all that
vile sure you're gonna get busted for it
no you can't [ __ ] around anymore though
huh that's good that's why god there's a
Tom Green on Twitter but his real name
is Tom Green and and my Twitter's Tom
Green live right now Dennis Miller's
ex-wife she's tweeting somebody is
tweeting under her name and it looks it
has all the photos of her with back in
the days Dennis Miller really stuck
talking a lot of smack Wow it might be
her but it might not be her she wrote
out a ten minute are you oh man
it's funny how you stop being funny you
know with that small penis of yours and
then I'm Krista I'll also wrote
something about I'm gonna write a new
pilot and write a new show and then she
wrote to her don't you get funnier first
are you serious yeah blocked
of course don't bash yes Dennis Miller's
wife or somebody that's not his wife is
writing hate every day
mad hate yeah that doesn't sound like
very much fun at all look at
Twitterverse you know yeah it does not
sound like very much fun so you have a
girlfriend or ex-girlfriend you told me
that I'm you guys watch my comedy
special with her family that was my
girlfriend that was my ex-girlfriend at
torture I don't I don't blame you for
the breakup of the relationship but but
my ex-girlfriend was her mother was
Mexican and her family's home other side
the family's Mexican so we were aware
over at their house and maybe they were
watching a comedy special and it was
awesome we all watched it together and
it was really great because yeah I was
here with this is Mexican family and
watching your special new specials
there's so much fun and yeah it was a
good time it was a good time so yeah we
only went out for like maybe six months
or something like that that girl and I
so I didn't didn't work out she was nice
person got to see my special though yeah
it was great oh yeah Oh Justine I would
have seen it anyways but that's that's
just when I happen to see it cuz I'm
just thinking her dad looking at you
yeah you wanna see some comedy check
this guy out eh yeah some comedy coming
up in q1 or less comedy yeah oh it's
great it was awesome that her blood in
blood out or American me yeah or that
Selena movie yeah yeah those are the
three biggest ghetto movies and Latinos
watch sometimes undercover yeah I let
him blood out Ameren I'm really American
me but Selena and I'm Grandma's Boy I'm
pretty got fingered ya know we went to
it was a family reunion we had went up
to with her family up in up in Fresno
actually so we were up there a nice
barbecue watched your comedy special
that's a good time yeah drank some
tequila Elia with a worm
there's no I know just just just the
tequila not the not the mezcal do they
put tequila in the worm worm it - no
it's immortal mezcal because uh my skull
is basically tequila but since it
doesn't come from tequila Jalisco it
can't be called tequila yeah I want to I
want to learn to habla espanol uno dos
tres uno dos tres cuatro Cinco Cinco
says I can speak I can
speak a bit because I speak French so I
owe the French comment allez-vous
je parle sympathy / / jokes we can the
Canadian friends we so it's very similar
to espanol pretty pretty similar and
what does do that's how are you yeah I
took German in high school I fight dry
sex even talk more is then nice
especially dodge Nick so good yeah you
wanted to learn to speak German
no man don't know other elective class I
could take yeah I took French was done
yeah all the friends all the girls took
friends and - - douchebags they want to
pick up on chicks - French yeah you know
I was my German class with all dudes and
three girls and man that their German
teacher man he was he was I'm Irish but
he spoke German and we show every day I
know like man I cheated through the
whole semester I got an A in a yeah you
should have taken French it would have
been a lot easier for you because it's
almost banished it's almost the same I
learned Beatles songs oh do mr. Sean
come give me Dinah come give me Dinah
huh come give me Dinah Wow shiny like a
sniffer you go bro the Black Forest
[ __ ] never go to Germany never nein
it's gay in name that's cool dog you
remember all that [ __ ] hi Jennifer
and I and I got a a another test cuz I
cheated yeah and I took the finals
some of the guys stole it and we made a
bunch of copy we studied it at home and
me I didn't studied when they [ __ ]
passed onto the little switch president
got his briefs real quick but he gave me
the final two the final what do they
look because I I used to bribe him right
so nice to work at Dodger Stadium
I took the Duchess - yeah I used to
sauce souvenir
to walk down the stadiums on selling
Dodger helmets and I have a bat I just
stood her up bro I have this brown
Dodger bat and I just well I have to put
teddy bears on them you know and wrap
them and I just saw pennants a nice walk
around going Dodger pen it's seven years
so I have a lot of Dodger pins and I
should give to my German teacher all the
time you know here's the little stone
for you I know you're a Dodger fan yeah
you get to see all the games all the
games oh yeah we're your baseball fans
all you wanted to work there no just
need a job that paid cash but it made
like 60 bucks a day man yeah cash in
high school yeah now some fat money to
all we're some ponies back then you know
one little high-top Reeboks those blue
ones yeah oh yeah and I got on baby
yeah yeah I remember those days when you
get those dreams see I'm a rad dreams of
things I want to get oh my god dude it
was always a skateboard or something
you're just kidding I was a Scott yeah
yes I wanted to have like a new
skateboard I'd spend the entire summer
move
order that Bulls brigade yeah that was
my arrow you [ __ ] yeah yeah Tony Hawk
got my skateboard had this scares my
hat's Canadian skateboard companies
skull skates yeah that was actually the
thing like when I grew up when I grew up
I was at Tony Hawk was my favorite human
being in the world and I was huge so you
can skateboard good yeah I'm okay I'm
okay you all you know that yeah hey
Rodrigo yeah yeah I'm pretty good at it
but I mean I'm not like he's pros you
know that you see on the internet doing
all their loop-de-loops not a Paul
Rodriguez Jr no gaming now Paul
Rodriguez is cool though yeah yeah
that's pretty amazing that he is that is
the
his father's an incredible comedian and
he's this incredible skateboarder what
some of the odds on that a lot of talent
in that family light up oh yeah how'd
that happen why didn't he just you'd
think he would have become a great
comedian nobody just happened to become
the best skateboarder in the world
how's that happen I don't know do the
Pearl drinking abroad that
that happened on the [ __ ] grind the
baddest [ __ ] Street skater dude y'all
baddest [ __ ] I got a shoes and [ __ ] yeah
I buzz tight I see uh Paul Rodriguez
senior at the car wash all the time
pinche Tom Green yeah whenever I go get
my car wash he came and did them I
wonder show right hand show as well as
his son also did the web of vision show
that was yeah so that's cool but yeah
the skateboarding then you know what
when I when my show went on MTV though
we've been on the air for about two
weeks and we got an email from Tony Hawk
and he wanted to be on the show so I got
to meet my hero within two weeks of
doing the show that's tight all my
heroes I got to meet how was that she I
do well you know risen yeah I was really
nervous he met me at my hotel no we
skateboard it through New York to this
to MTV it was pretty awesome yeah what's
up now now we're buddies I did like I
mean he's a friend of mine I don't see
him all the time because he's always
traveling and but but I got to know him
very well over the years very nice nice
guy he's a we did a we put a skateboard
out I put my own skateboard out with his
company birdhouse a few years ago so I
basically got to be like a professional
skateboarder for a minute even though I
didn't really deserve to be I still got
to be slipped it in yeah that was pretty
cool
so there's a Tom Green skateboard out
there somewhere yeah I don't know if
it's available anymore but for a few
years we did that it was fun and I went
on tour with Tony and the skaters we
toured around the country skating I
would basically you know I wasn't very
good though I mean when you're when
you're when you're skating with those
guys you you're no good anymore that's
tired man I was like I'm like a really
good skateboarder if I'm skateboarding
with people who don't skateboard but if
I go with our best professional
skateboarders in the world I'm I'm like
a shitty skateboarder like a cruiser
yeah man my hero remember know the kid I
like I like Tony Hawk but before that I
wanted to meet Mary Lou Retton yeah
why'd I don't know why man I just want
to give a little high five yeah I
suppose you do a little trick yeah
feel like the powder her handle yeah
yeah that's really what she was bad as
[ __ ] udon oh that's why I don't like
hanging around with talented people you
know like when I started hanging around
with all these professional
skateboarders all of a sudden I didn't
feel like a very good skateboarder I
like hanging around with talentless
people oh yeah and like people that
aren't very smart it just makes me feel
so much better about myself I can count
yeah yeah exactly it's great so you know
that's why it's not really very fun when
you hang out with me and my and my
friends I'm the smartest one I'm the
most talented so that gives you an
indication of the kind of people that I
hang around Lord it's not pleasant it's
not pleasant but no that's not true what
I just said is not true I'm not lying
because I've got this thing where I
don't consider it a lie if I acknowledge
that it was a lie within one minute of
the lie it's it's a joke then a lot of a
lot of jokes are just lies yeah like you
know I I what I just said
all my friends are talentless I like
being around talentless people because
it makes me feel smart that's just a
joke but it's also just a lie yeah but
if you let sometimes you tell those lies
for a joke and then everyone believes it
and then you don't want to say that it's
a lie because you feel so good that
everyone believes it look I did one once
to my mother I was out for lunch with my
mother and for some reason I wanted to
tell her that I was a CIA agent for no
reason whatsoever I was as we were
eating lunch and I just just popped into
my head that I wanted to tell her this I
think I just wanted her to think that my
life was more interesting that it had
actually become
I'm always on airplanes and traveling
around doing stand-up and I went to
Afghanistan to do stand-up for the US
military I did USO tour so it's been
over in Afghanistan and I'm back from
Afghanistan I'm eating lunch with my
mother and I just for whatever reason
said mom I I have to tell you something
and I need you to promise me that you're
not gonna tell Dad and then you're not
gonna tell anybody and she said okay
well I'm sure of course what what is it
so well this is very very important you
can promise me you really won't tell
anybody because you know it could really
hurt me and affect my life in a very bad
way but I have to tell somebody cuz
haven't been able to tell anybody she's
oh okay well what is it it sounds it
sounds serious I said well you know I'm
traveling all the time and you know I
just was in Afghanistan and I went to
Iraq and I know I told you I was over
there doing comedy but actually I'm uh
I'm in the CIA and the comedy is a cover
and my mother's worried break gullible
because she doesn't want to believe that
I would ever lie to her so everything I
tell her is always believed and she
looked at me in silence and I said but
there's more that you need to know and I
have to talk to someone about it and
only person I can talk to about it as
you and you're the only person that I
can trust but I've killed people I've
had to kill people she looked at me and
she said how many people have you killed
I said I've killed
six people and then I started laughing
because I couldn't believe she believed
me and then she still believed me even
after I was laughing for some reason
that's how much she wants to believe
that her son wouldn't lie to her and
then I told her I was lying and then she
said why would you do that and I said
well was just a joke just a joke
really there was nothing clever about it
it was just a straight-up lie straight
[ __ ] with her [ __ ] but I think
sometimes like in those moments where
you're lying you also kind of get to be
a CIA agent for a minute you know if
like for a minute before I cracked up I
actually was a CIA agent
yeah I actually had killed people and
then it was it was exciting for me and
my brother angel the liar heck yeah all
my nephews convinced that him and Tony
Hawk hung out yeah tell me that one time
we're chilling he hung that him Antonio
could move our brothers to skateboard
with that um graffiti artist Chaka
uh-huh the famous one they wrote on a
wall in a hurry with Chaka
yeah Chaka Khan yeah yeah tiger you the
tag okay not Chaka Khan he wrote you a
hero Chuck all over the world yeah I CH
aka and Nirvana put Chaka did he write
it in shock
no just okay that's good and Chuck yeah
and so my brother knew that guy and so I
don't know where my brother should
always steal skateboards from kids I
give you an F your skateboard outside to
go get a Slurpee my bro didn't run by
and take it yeah so he was that guy and
he had told my I guess my nephews and my
son that he knew Tony Hawk about him
right
grew up with him right lie [ __ ]
yeah we're all hanging out you know in
dinner in San Diego we're having dinner
after a comedy show and then my son just
blurts out my dad knows Tony Hawk and I
learned I did I do
don't tell lies but you won't tell
people that you will never tell them
that it's not a light so later on yeah I
think I might start lying more today
after this conversation
why don't we yeah lie just more probably
be a good way to get ahead in this
business just lie your way through it
I mean I know there's obviously ethical
and moral reasons not to but I've lived
the last 44 years not really considering
myself to be a liar I think I might try
the other way
I know think of some good lies for this
afternoon
something something completely
unverifiable you know like I ran into
Steven Spielberg at Starbucks they tell
my manager that today I have a manager
that's a Hollywood things I've gotten uh
yes we baseball players why do I have a
manager what do I need and what needs to
be managed the regardless I do and I'm
gonna tell him that I ran into Steven
Spielberg at the Starbucks and he wants
me to come in for a meeting and I'm
gonna stretch it out for a week he's
gonna get all excited he's gonna think
that we're gonna get some movie deal and
make money and then I'd si no I'm just
lying just a lie no reason whatsoever
that'll be comedy yeah it's believable
but unnecessary lies to whatever mark
Tony put yeah bro I ran into Kevin Hart
yeah he was working out of um out of our
the veggie girl with a script yeah
and hid in here a pen yeah I saw he saw
me and my eyes you're Felipe you're the
guy I need yeah yeah it won't work
without you but I don't take a [ __ ] and
ask - what's the restroom so everybody
gets to talk to him so I've been trying
to get a hold him on Instagram right now
and then people will believe that
because they know that I'm that lame
yeah I get his phone number right there
and make the deal happen I wonder how
long it would take to lose all of your
friends and relations with all the
people you know like if you just started
lying to do that easy but everything how
about all the fools that we know that
lie anyways though yeah I do Tom a
buncha rocks like oh my god you know
this guy he said out of nowhere Tom I
own an honest Wagner baseball card yeah
there's like three in the world in this
[ __ ] dusty [ __ ] hasn't once
got a party to a guy staying next to us
who didn't put in no money into this
marijuana joint uh-huh who needs a ride
home after this session yeah it looks
like a tow truck driver we're all
comedians but he only on this Wagner
baseball card yeah you guys got a
marijuana joint that you're we're
heading on or is that a lie no no we got
to I got some weed though if you want a
puff after got some green for Tom Green
and then cut it off off mic yeah other
cut comics hung out with us say they
played whist they played football with
Peyton Manning yeah nah full of flies
talking to who's Brett Favre full right
for a dog I played a I played football
with Brett Favre and called his dog I
was playing for Tulane I like that I'm
gonna say I ran into Peyton Manning
today - that's believable believe it
he's from Ottawa you know yeah you're
gonna run it I'm gonna I'm gonna die I'm
really gonna do this actually and then
I'm gonna document it and you know and
on my web show or something we should do
the biggest lie in april fools
yeah that's what I'm saying leading up
to it mmm little lies - the biggest lie
ever yes I wonder if we could coordinate
our lies so that they worked to our
advantage
hell yeah our mutual advantage will be
enough hype yeah hype start with a lie
right hell yeah
so hype is mostly right right see maybe
that's my problem you have the script or
any reason yeah that could be my problem
in in show business I don't lie enough
I'm too on a little bit I'm an honest
Canadian I need to start lying more
you're gonna be lying like the Hamptons
good it'd be a good career move
yeah I'm gonna start doing that today
okay all uh-oh I'll text you I'll let
you know what happens okay yeah start a
band the liars yeah I'm gonna say that I
ran into Steven Spielberg and I tell my
manager who manages me on periscope it
I'm gonna tell him I ran to Steven
Spielberg and he wants me to come in for
a meeting
about a movie that he's doing and then
I'm gonna have my manager call over to
Steven Spielberg's office to arrange the
time for the meeting and then they're
gonna tell him Steven Spielberg didn't
run into [ __ ] Tom at a [ __ ]
Starbucks and then he's gonna call me
and he's gonna say they said that he
didn't run into you and then I'm gonna
deny it
and I'm gonna say they must have not got
the message I'm gonna have him call back
and tell him that's Hollywood for you
until he accuses me of being a liar what
are you talking about
I will never admit that I lied about it
and then each day I'm gonna come up with
an that says well it's gonna be a lie a
day for a year one lie one unnecessary
lie per day for a year and in a year
from now let's see if my life is better
or worse that [ __ ] would be better yeah
more friends yeah more friends probably
be living in you know grease or
something like that on a [ __ ] yacht
or something one lie a day led me here
this honesty shit's not working out for
me
that should know work doing a web show
in a warehouse
I lied once a day
some what would you lie about if your
actual life to someone I do I'll [ __ ]
have some crazy-ass lies dog I'm dan I'm
not one fat fool than [ __ ] things one
day he'll be thin no you're alive those
who get any work to get ahead to get
ahead [ __ ] no I don't like that dude I
like little [ __ ] bag lies and [ __ ]
pretty light so mondo yeah mondo that
ladder will hold me no I never did none
of that [ __ ] scam was that [ __ ] when
you're saying that [ __ ] I was thinking
about [ __ ] tell people my podcast is
rated on the top 20 every [ __ ] with
every [ __ ] week ain't nothing then
that I go check hey you know that guy's
[ __ ] podcast is top 20 hey you know
that guy's podcast top 20 oh you know
it's top 20 over there
you know I lied once on Twitter once
just to see what would happen would you
say well it was a weird lie like I'm
friends with carrot top you know the
carrots on his fun have to say the
comedian carrot top it's carrot top yeah
so I'm friends with carrot top legend
he's an amazing have you seen a show
it's incredible show right
so he'll props I was doing I was doing
shows in Vegas last year and I went to
his show and we became friends actually
we did a film with the Trailer Park Boys
as well conky dog donkey we did a movie
called swearnet that's how I met you
carrot top we got Julian right here
absolutely yeah so I got a one day I got
a you know carrot oven nice you know we
text each other sometimes sometimes he
sends me funny photos so he was at a
Rolling Stones concert in in Vegas and
he was like standing like two feet from
the stage and he sent me a text it up
picture from a cell phone of Mick Jagger
right so then I had the picture now so I
just thought oh this will be cool I'm
gonna tweet out this picture but I'm
gonna tell everybody that I took it
and I just said look at this right now
I'm here at the Rolling Stones concert
front-row seats right and I tweeted ups
gonna win
I felt like lying to everybody and
literally the next you know months
people were coming up to me and I only
left the photo up there for a couple
hours cuz I was a realized I was
embarrassed about the you know you can't
take the lie back on Twitter now by
deleting it it's still it's still a lie
I figured by deleting it it was like
saying that it it wasn't true but really
it was still true in many people's minds
people would come up to me all the time
the old man how was that concert man it
was [ __ ] awesome my deficit was a lie
and then people are so disappointed but
maybe that's the way to do it maybe
maybe I'm gonna start maybe a daily lie
tweet yes an incredible light wheat
every day that could spread quick create
more buzz and [ __ ] yeah create more buzz
equip more buzz and real buzz oh here
buzzing around on the net lie about the
amount of people listening to my podcast
we've got a million downloads on my
podcast this week I just launched a new
podcast by the way it's it's on iTunes
this is true it's called the Tom Green
radio show so everybody subscribed to it
it's on the play it Network and and and
on iTunes but anyways we just launched
it last week and we had a million
downloads Wow
so it's really incredible that's bitchin
dude doing really really well like a lie
like that you know doing really well I
think a lot of this business is based on
that Bell right yeah false hype or you
say yeah we were we were mentioned on
Howard Stern yeah we were actually yeah
well our Stern told somebody what's up
fool yeah and as I said podcast
bababooey Papa bunny hey
I know oh yeah don't believe the hype
Public Enemy so anyways but I do have
this new podcast is doing great really
good London a lot of those thing to it
my friends are listening to it oh my
friends all your homies yeah all the
Canadians and Mexicans yeah hell yeah
absolutely
so what do you guys do after this after
the show what are you doing for the rest
of the day after this oh I just signed
up to the YMCA in Glendale bro hell yeah
how my whole family my Lisa my wife
that's my wife um Isaac Hayes that's my
stepson more Isaac with Jam it is six
dollars a month from three yes yeah I
think I want people there and they're
all Russia's let old Armenian old people
I'm the youngest I know Jay over here
bro you're gonna get healthy yeah so I
signed up to the gym so I might look
good little swimming later bro little
digs yeah you try to eat healthy own
vegan yeah I drink alcohol no no no no
anymore I get crazy where'd you go yeah
yeah I'm learning that it's not a good
idea to drink alcohol yeah man after I
was doing a lot of partying man me one
time man I was partying with um the Fox
you know I'm a kiss the band Kiss yeah I
was partying with a member of the Fox
when they kicked out they kicked up
Peter Criss Oh net though the guy with a
fox
partying with a fox okay yeah man
see that's a good like and a lot of
who's that I was a lie yeah I never
thought it was a fire I put on some guy
named Fox knows a lie and they were poor
they get from kiss but man what time I
did tell people that I saw the guy the
Fox from kids and we hung out but all
the big lie and nobody could prove it
broken who the [ __ ] gonna know the Fox
is hell yeah underneath at make up
nobody yeah hey man when did now when
did you stop drinking um 2009 okay yeah
that's pretty good
I haven't actually officially quit yet
but I've cut back so much in the last
three months only this is a driver
though you do let go I'm Canadian I
assume that
drinking is alright you know you grow up
drinking all the time then you start
doing stand-up you're tooling around the
country you're in clubs every night
drink a couple of shots of whiskey after
the show a little Moosehead beer yeah
yeah little Musetta yeah yeah how many
young guys are in Canada
that's a good question whether it
improves I think there's 11 oh yeah but
there could be 15 it's something like
that
I mean they're Canada's the
second-largest country in the world but
that's by landmass and most of it is
empty as snow most of the country is
completely empty so there's no comedy
clubs in Tuktoyaktuk
there's no comedy clubs up in the
northern part of Canada but there's one
in Vancouver Ottawa Saint John's
Newfoundland Hamilton Windsor close
maybe maybe I haven't been to Windsor
that's the only Canadian city I haven't
been - I've been to Windsor we're now
working with Russell Peters yeah nice
yeah
Russell's awesome Canadian Canadian yes
yeah paisan yeah see how an
autobiography you wrote a book I did
yeah Hollywood causes cancer that's how
I'm green story yes is the author by
would be fool no lies all true all true
I wish a lot of the stuff I wrote and it
wasn't true there's a lot of weird
stories in there I think the book might
not be available anymore and I'm
actually glad that I Kindle that
anywhere you can find it I hope not no I
hope not you know sometimes you sit down
to write a book and you think I want to
be honest and then you think 10 years
later
damn why did I say that why did I tell
everybody everything well it's my life
story I guess I got to tell people
everything and you go no there's some
things I don't want people to know now
that I'm saying this probably everyone's
gonna listening is probably gonna be
more likely to read the book so I should
probably say that I love the book and
ask everyone to go read it yeah I wish
when the book came out I had told people
not to read the book might
sold more copies do you have a copy
although then they would have read it so
would have been a real trade-off there
but now I know I add a lot of crazy fun
stories in the book too you know I you
know it was a pretty exciting time when
the show got picked up by MTV I've been
doing the show I've been doing and I'll
tell you some stories from the book but
I've been making an effort lately when I
go on podcasts you know we all go on
podcasts now right they're fun to do and
I've been making an effort lately to not
just tell stories about myself but also
to just try to talk about weird subjects
yeah like what we've been doing today
I think that's kind of a fun thing cuz a
lot of times when you go on podcast you
end up sort of telling all the same
stories yeah no I just like this whole
lighting thing we came up with like I'm
really gonna do that but I will tell you
some of the stories that I can tell you
some stories start on periscope with
that life yeah I mean but the book was
photos fun right in the book because
like a lot of crazy things happened I
mean had this crazy little show and then
all of a sudden was on MTV and all of a
sudden I got to do all these things I'd
never dreamed I would get to do let go
on the Letterman Show I was a huge
Letterman fan growing up I wanted to be
like David Letterman so that was always
my dream that's why I have the the tea
the web Oh vision show in the in the
warehouse in did a co-host in that show
right oh yeah hosting it yeah hosted
Letterman oh yeah that was crazy
I got called my manager called me
because I have a manager I I don't know
it's hard to tell that story without
telling what happened right you know
like my manager called me and told me
that that Letterman wanted me to host
the show the next day so I was here in
Los Angeles and I got a call from my
manager and he said hey Letterman wants
you to host the show tomorrow and I like
[ __ ] this is crazy so I went to the
airport and I flew to New York and I
hosted Letterman but it was it was
pretty pretty insane oh that like pretty
insane experience it was like it was
insane because you know you grow up your
whole life idolizing Letterman and then
now
they played the opening song and then
they say your name and then you're
walking out onto the set at the Ed
Sullivan Theater and Paul Shaffer was
there and I had to write my own
monologue and I wrote the monologue and
you know on the plane and then and it
was and and and you know I've had a lot
of times in my life where like I've had
things that were amazing opportunities
that I just couldn't do because I was
too nervous
and this was one of those things that I
couldn't do that to myself I knew I had
to do it but it was horrifying was a
horrifying experience I think for some
reason like I don't know like like I've
not done certain things that I should
have done because I was too afraid to do
it and I look back and I think wow I
wish I I wish I had done that but I was
too afraid you know I get social anxiety
it's a weird thing because you know I
get up on stage every night do stand-up
for some reason I can do that but
sometimes when it involves just sort of
something that's I mean not in my
control yeah I get total anxiety like I
won't I don't like going to parties
because I know that I'm gonna have to
you know socialize with people so
occasionally though I can go to a party
like if it's in a trailer park in Joshua
Tree yeah then I can go trailer park
boys right here and then I'm always glad
I do because it you know we would have
never met I wouldn't be here doing this
podcast make new friends when you get
out of the house right yeah yeah so I
got to get out more I get social anxiety
but but yeah that was pretty cool
lots of weird stories in that book but I
fear I feel weird telling the stories
sometimes because they're laid there
like a lot of them are good stories and
I don't like kind of like yeah and then
there was a time a hosted Letterman I
feel like an [ __ ]
yeah you know but I guess that's what
you got to do are you even just saying
my manager called me yeah makes me feel
like an [ __ ] who the [ __ ] this guy
with this [ __ ] manager [ __ ] off
who you got a manager ooh
my publicist called yeah exactly right
it's almost a good reason to not have a
publicist my exterminator called Taurus
yeah that's that's more like roaches are
under control my nanny's out of control
yeah I'm not that busy that I need a
manager
why do I have to manage all those people
who actually post up by this Ram I'm
meeting my my my living room designer
yeah yeah really you need so much to
tell you how to put in your own labor
room put the couch there in front of the
television
here lies Tom I'm a meeting was a
personal dresser today yeah this guy's
after that we're doing a movie one time
and the main act of the movie had his
personal dresses are like we already had
costumers costume you know for the movie
but discover a friend that the Howard
Stern that tells him how to wear the
scarf hardware that hat yeah what belt
to wear what socks and nobody else gonna
see what shoes was shoelaces yeah
there's a lot of that stuff type of
stuff in my in the book because it's
it's about me moving to Hollywood and
being overwhelmed by the absurdity of
show business coming from Canada I was
no show business right I was a captain
in the Canadian Army we have an army so
we grew up in like army bases and stuff
furthest thing ever from from Hollywood
so so military-to-military all over
Canada
yeah when I was a kid till I was around
8 years old we moved every year to
different military bases and stuff and
then you know so when I moved down to LA
it was very strange cuz you know you're
sort of surrounded by the show business
stuff it's weird I've been here 15 years
now though I've got a I think I'm even
tired of making fun of it yes I am I've
been here so long you can't make fun of
something that you sort of have to
- bye Norma and you get again some car
accident Hollywood and Vine and instead
of exchanging insurance during change
exchange eight-by-tens yeah yeah it's I
just got a new car like an old car that
I got in Craigslist so I can old beat-up
Oldsmobile 1968 Oldsmobile it's all
pretty cool a four-door I'm sorry Doris
two-door yeah it's sweet it doesn't work
it was really long car yeah it's it's
yeah I'll show you a picture of it like
a boat I mean I actually if it is I
won't show you a picture because that's
just gonna be kind of annoying to the
people listening I know don't watch it
on you on our Instagram I'm gonna show
you guys a picture but everyone we're
talking to well you can't see so what's
up fool jellies coming up you want to
tell people your dates yeah absolutely I
got Houston improv Austin can I pull out
my yeah pull actually look yeah cuz I
don't know where I'm gonna be because
I'm so busy what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
tellest am I ever a [ __ ] [ __ ]
today yeah Jimmy maybe call my manager
do me any celebrity that you want to
just punch because you know they were
full of [ __ ] but I want to punch myself
right now I've decided that I'm not
going to talk [ __ ] about celebrities
anymore that I mean that I hate like
when I meet so much to do that before
yeah I didn't nobody told me that this
was a small town nobody told me that if
you talk [ __ ] about 20 people you never
work again
damn we had a further Smith last week
nah
well he's at one of the classic stories
huh look Jamie once told the whole story
oh really
yeah you listed that's why everybody in
Los Angeles is happy all the time when
they see you they're just pretending
yeah really
oh hi so great to see you in the back
their head they're saying on this
[ __ ] [ __ ] hook my role yeah well
my phone's not opening but is an Jose
Improv I'm gonna be in wiseguys in Utah
and all the dates are on Tom Green Comm
just go to Tom Green Comm and click on
the tour dates if you are anywhere in
this country and I might be performing
there why is getting Utah I was just
there and way ok wise guy seen you
before yeah well a couple times yeah I
like that look at club life yeah and a
few other places too
oh I'm gonna be Caroline's in New York
in December that's what's up I never
been there
yeah that's we have I play there I love
playing in New York that's fun but yeah
so just traveling around doing it and
doing the web low-vision you got to come
back to the web evasion show and then
I'm bringing my podcast on the road with
me too I have this portable digital
recorder and microphone and I once in a
while I'm gonna do my podcast where I
just walk down the street and just talk
to everybody that makes eye contact with
me you're skateboarding one telling
periscope Oh watching us on board yeah
for about five minutes
I got escaped you're Hudson Beach yeah
yeah that's right I've got a new
skateboard that is small enough to fit
in my luggage and I bring it with me on
tour and that's what I do to keep from
losing my mind is during the day I'll go
skateboard around the around the town Oh
screw that day I will watching your host
game boy that's a man my man my fat ass
get up yeah it's my size but don't don't
don't take up skateboarding later in
life I'm done yeah you should never
start learning skateboarding after the
age of 20 yeah then you just you're just
gonna fall let it go or Drigo let it go
it's how we're teaching a philip how to
ollie
I broke my leg I broke my leg five years
ago and I I just I don't do any job
so any more just just straight cruising
cool man cool man everybody listen to my
podcast you come back on my podcast YES
on the new pot you know anything else
your favorite A Tribe Called Quest album
Low End Theory hell yeah yeah Academy
nation of millions - takes a Nation oh
yeah both of their second albums raising
hell oh yeah yeah raising I'll do this
yeah yeah my adidas favorite Tribe
Called Quest song is probably buggin out
oh yeah oh yeah yeah
though those were the ones that's all
the same year same well publication of
millions and lo in theory a thinker
oh no nation millions was maybe a couple
years before yeah that's my era of
hip-hop absolutely the golden era yeah
those were those were those were the
years yeah I don't know what's happened
to music the dance is your gas to the
hub did you watch the MTV Awards the
other night no I just thought I don't
know I saw that I saw that I saw the
important parts on Instagram yeah I
liked the performance by the weekend
that was incredible that was the only
part I liked oh and Justin Bieber was
pretty good you want the VMAs got a
support motion a dance about homeboy
running for president and [ __ ] just do
that part when oh come on us yeah
is he running for president he's say
he's running into 20 Wow 20 20
he's got my vote fewer than 20 20 people
have a vision all right people
well thank you Tom grief including a
word so full part yeah afraid to be here
yes you oh yeah man yeah man a real
Canadian Yemen yeah mr. wimple business
go to Tom Green Comm it links to
everything Tom Green Comm it goes to my
facebook my Instagram all that stuff and
and listen to the podcast on iTunes and
go to the donut shop
Arwen zzzz yes to go to the donut Prince
donut shop on Wednesdays if you're in
Los Angeles in
beautiful downtown Burbank that is stuff
far better than the best
just wanna be practicing I don't see
heads and I crap only I'm really a nice
guy still I gotta go to the ladies I'm
thinking why when I begin Chuck is Here
I am heading the right way can i will
stop there's some dough in the top but I
don't wear a box watch play you wanna
jump like an scotch
climb the ranks so considerate I'm not
take control of your system in a minute
you wanna get with this swing the
countdown 1 2 3 4 smooth it out now
check the Oh